Far Cry primal it's coming and yes it is
another Far Cry game battling the
wildlife liberating the locals and
skinning animals are indeed familiar
tasks from the series well you will find
some fresh meat in this carcass Far Cry
primal is all about man versus nature
this means more hunting more gathering
and more often than not fighting a
vicious predator there are still other
human tribes to fight but most conflicts
and trial arise from dangers you'll find
in the wilderness
meaning more tense moment to moment
exploration
there are no guns or explosives in
Primal the only weapons you have are
those you can make from wood stone and
natural materials this means you'll rely
on your bow and stealth situations your
club and melee combat and your spear
filling in the rest being outnumbered is
much more of a problem this time around
further pushing your drive to sneak
about for quiet takedown as opposed to
the experience based progression of Far
Cry 4 primal grants you specialists
these characters are strewn throughout
the wilderness and by upgrading their
huts in your home village you'll unlock
new powers and abilities throughout your
playthrough although you could control a
tiger in Far Cry 4 primal expands this
idea into a full progression tree by
taming specific wild animals like the
owl wolf or bear you can scout enemy
camps order vicious attacks and ride
bigger predators into the fray by
upgrading one of your specialists will
unlock more possible animals to control
the wilderness itself is denser packed
with more trees more types of animals or
elaborate caves and higher number of
plants to facilitate the increased time
you spend hunting and gathering you can
also collect more materials than those
you find from plants and animals in fact
hardwood and slate are two of the most
essential ingredients for growing your
village
before the Sun goes down you'll want to
stock up on plenty of wood and animal
fat because torches not only help with
visibility but they also keep predators
at bay and at night there are a lot of
predators and they're also more
aggressive so if you're venturing out to
find some of the rare plants that only
blossom under the night make sure you're
prepared with the necessary supplies
there you have it six ways Far Cry
primal strays from its predecessor for
more on primal and on over to
gamespot.com